[موسيقى]
التنافس على منطقه الشمال النيجيري يشعل
حربا غير مسبوقه بين تنظيم داعش وجمعت
بوكو حرام ذوي الانفجارات القويه واطلاق
الرصاص يتواصلان ويزدادان كثافه مع ساعات
الليل بين ابرز جمعتين متطرفين في نيجيريا
جوله القتال الحديثه بدات منذ اسابيع
باقتحام مقاتلين من بوك حرام معسكرات غربي
افريقيا حينها اطلق ابو بكر قناي احد كبار
قاده بوكو حرام هجوما على جزيرتين يسيطر
عليهما داعش واجبره على التراجع قبل ان
يقتحم سجنا ويفرج عن العديد من المعتقلين
والرهائن ومن بعيد فهناك من ينظر للقتال
بعين الرضا فالاستخبارات النيجيريه تراقب
ما يحدث بين الجماعتين المتطرفتين
وتطوراته
من الصعب اعطاء حصيله تشمل الجانبين لكن
الارقام هائله نتحدث عن اكثر من 200 قتيل
فقط في جمعه تورو قرب الحدود مع النيجر
حرب الهيمنه على حوض بحيرات تشاد ومحيطه
التي يخوضها حلفاء سابقون حصدت ارواح اكثر
من 200 عنصر من جماعه بوكو حرام نهايه
الشهر الماضي حروب التنافس التي تدور بين
الجماعتين كان سبقها تحالف وثيق فتنظيم
داعش الخصم المرير لبوكو حرام كان جزءا من
الجماعه المتشدده قبل انشقاقه منذ سنوات
ليخوض الجانبان معارك ضد بعضهما وضد
القوات المسلحه النيجيريه حنان المصري
العربيه